hi I'm mano marks developer advocate on
the Google
this is a second video in a series of
four designed to show you how to get
started with the Google Maps JavaScript
API and the first episode of the series
we cover creating and customizing your
first map
in this episode we'll cover creating an
API key using an API key enables you to
monitor your applications Maps API usage
ensure that Google can contact you about
your application if necessary if your
applications Maps API usage exceeds the
usage limits in a very rare condition
you must know the Maps API using it in
API key in order to purchase additional
quota to get an API key visit the Google
API console at this URL if necessary log
in to your Google account
a quick note about which account to use
if you're planning to use the map for
your own personal use and it will always
be in your control you can go ahead and
use your own account however if you're
planning to use it
for an organization that you work for
consider using a shared Google account
that other people can access that way if
you're no longer working on the Maps
project or you aren't available for some
reason others can access the account and
receive any notifications that might be
necessary
you can also accomplish this by sharing
the project with others the ownership of
the account and ownership of the project
should probably stay with the map that's
doubly true if you're creating the map
for a customer to create a key either
select an existing project or create a
new one to create a new project select
the project list and click on create
project after you load or create a
project click on the services tab then
scroll down to the Google Maps API v3
and click the button to turn it off
finally click on the API access tab then
click on the create new browser key this
should you should see this box asking
for domains but the domains that you
will be using for this Maps API key this
will prevent others from using the API
key on their sites okay that's all there
is to it in the next video we'll cover
using
API key when you load the JavaScript API
and the basic parameters of the
JavaScript loader